[Música]
francia rompió hoy su récord de
contagios diarios de kobe 19 al recordar
más de
368.000 mientras que la agencia europea
de medicamentos advirtió que no hay que
bajar la guardia y considerar al
coronavirus como una enfermedad leve
el parlamento del reino unido- le pide
rendir cuentas al gobierno de boris
johnson esto luego de que la cadena itv
denunciara que los funcionarios
asistieron a una fiesta de más de 100
personas en mayo de 2020 cuando las
restricciones por la pandemia lo impedía
la prisión de guantánamo cumple 20 años
de funcionamiento amnistía internacional
denuncia que allí las autoridades de
eeuu han torturado e incluso
desaparecido a varios reclusos tendremos
análisis en minutos
bienvenidos a esta emisión informativa
de france 24 yo soy marinera calle y es
un placer estar con ustedes y comenzamos
con noticias del cobi 19 en europa
porque francia anunció un nuevo récord
de contagios diarios confirmando más de
368.000 los casos están disparados en el
país galo hace tan sólo tres semanas
francia superó por primera vez en toda
la pandemia los 100.000 positivos en un
solo día y ahora esta cifra está cada
vez más cerca de los 400.000 en francia
los contagios han ido en aumento desde
que la variante omicron se ha convertido
en la dominante
y en medio del repunte del cob y 19 en
el 'viejo continente' la agencia europea
de medicamentos le pidió a los países
que no se olviden que todavía estamos en
una pandemia y no en un virus endémico
marco cavaleri el jefe de estrategia de
vacunación de la ema alertó que la
variante omicron se está propagando
rápidamente y que esto puede sobrecargar
los hospitales además advirtió que
aunque la vacuna sirve esta medida
también tiene sus límites
hay dos preocupaciones la primera es que
si tenemos una estrategia en la que
ofrecemos refuerzos digamos
aproximadamente cada cuatro meses
terminaremos potencialmente teniendo
problemas con la respuesta inmunitaria
pons y en segundo lugar por supuesto
existe el riesgo de fatigar a la
población con la administración continua
de refuerzos busters y el primer
ministro británico boris johnson el más
votado en 30 años está en la cuerda
floja el parlamento situaba varios
funcionarios de su gobierno por las
fiestas en downing street durante los
confinamientos luego de una nueva
revelación que habla de una reunión
adicional a las que ya se conocían
martes boris johnson rehusó dar
explicaciones y envió a un secretario de
bajo perfil también se abrió una
investigación interna a la que se podría
sumar la de la policía metropolitana
tiene más detalles lluís muchos
fiestas pandémicas llevan al límite al
gobierno británico la emisora itv reveló
una invitación de martín reynolds
secretario privado del primer ministro
boris johnson a una reunión de más de
100 personas cargadas de alcohol en
downing street- del 20 de mayo de 2020
el parlamento pidió la comparecencia de
johnson para que reconociera o negara su
asistencia pero el gobierno envió un
funcionario de bajo perfil
me disculpo no sin reservas por el
malestar que han causado estas
acusaciones el primer ministro ha pedido
que se lleve a cabo una investigación
ustedes
jesús la fiesta se celebró cuando el
país vivía fuertes restricciones con
escuelas cerradas y sin posibilidad de
despedirse de familiares víctimas de
kobe 19 el mismo día de la reunión el
secretario de cultura había hecho el
siguiente recordatorio terminado a
encontrar formas creativas y sin
multitudes de navegar por el coronavirus
es el mayor desafío para nuestros
escritores de recreación y ocio en este
momento se suena una alta funcionaria
del gobierno su grey con forma de mano
dura está investigando cinco fiestas en
departamentos gubernamentales
la policía ha pedido información para
iniciar una investigación
el partido laborista pide
responsabilidades es upson creo que su
ausencia lo dice todo igual que su
sonrisa ante los medios de comunicación
el público ya ha sacado sus propias
conclusiones puede huir pero no puede
esconderse lee kang
no es la primera crisis de boris johnson
por las fiestas en diciembre se conoció
que en las navidades de 2020 en downing
street también se saltaron las
restricciones detrás de las revelaciones
estaría dominique cummings antiguo
asesor que dejó el cargo por enfrentarse
con la actual esposa de boris johnson
el presidente de méxico andrés manuel
lópez obrador afirmó que estaba muy bien
un día después de que se confirmó que
tenía cobit 19 por segunda vez el
mandatario grabó un vídeo para difundir
en su rueda de prensa diaria en el se le
notó la voz carrasposa y se tomó en
directo la temperatura y también la
oxigenación en sangre desde el
aislamiento lópez obrador agregó que
tiene dolor de garganta y un poco de
dolor en el cuerpo esto fue lo que dijo
qué es lo que tengo
ardor en la garganta es como una gripe
con ronquera
un poquito de dolor de cuerpo al
principio
estoy tomando
paracetamol
y me siento bastante bien entonces
creo que
afortunadamente no vamos a necesitar
hospitalizarlos ni vamos a sufrir
pasamos ahora a eeuu el presidente de la
reserva federal y era un powel se
postuló este martes para un segundo
mandato al frente del organismo su
prioridad será luchar contra la elevada
inflación a pesar de que esto le puede
quitar margen de maniobra para lograr el
aumento del empleo estos son los dos
objetivos asignados al banco central hoy
powell habló ante el comité del senado
defendiendo su nominación nuestro
corresponsal en washington cristóbal
vázquez nos explica más
richard clarida subdirector de la
reserva federal de eeuu presentó su
renuncia al presidente bailén tras las
investigaciones de corrupción que lo
acusan de insight rating es decir de
invertir y transar en la bolsa de nueva
york con información confidencial
privilegiada de movimientos que hizo la
reserva federal para dinamizar la
economía en eeuu concretamente claridad
retiró dinero de un fondo de acciones
cuando los mercados estaban a la baja
por cuenta de la pandemia y volvió a
invertirlo en ese mismo fondo días antes
de que la reserva federal anunciara
medidas para reactivar la economía y los
mercados financieros
la renuncia de claridad viene después de
la renuncia de robert kaplan y erika
rosenberg que dirigían las oficinas de
la reserva federal en boston in dallas
por hacer maniobras similares con
información privilegiada como una
epidemia ética y legal en los niveles
más altos de la reserva federal así
califican algunos activistas lo ocurrido
entretanto joan pau el director de la
reserva federal asistió hoy a su
audiencia de confirmación en el comité
bancario del senado para asumir su
segundo mandato a cargo de la fecha
powell había sido inicialmente nombrado
en el cargo por el ex presidente don
otro
hoy hace 20 años comenzó a funcionar la
prisión de guantánamo ubicada en una
base naval estadounidense en el este de
cuba un nuevo informe de amnistía
internacional denuncia que los presos
que han pasado por allí han sido
torturados no han tenido asistencia
médica adecuada y tampoco un juicio con
todas las garantías
eeuu ha utilizado esa cárcel para las
personas que detuvo en afganistán e irak
luego de los ataques del 11 de
septiembre de 2001 previamente blanca
hernández portavoz de amnistía
internacional sobre eeuu nos explicó que
no ha hecho yo vaivén como presidente
para cerrar guantánamo a pesar de que
desde el 2009 prometió que lo haría
si este es un tema que llevamos muchos
años luchando para conseguir que por fin
se cierre el centro de detención de
guantánamo y es verdad que el presidente
obama prometió que cerraría la base de
detención y yo byron porque pertenecía a
ese equipo que había tomado esa decisión
desde que bailén está en el gobierno y
lamentamos que solo un detenido
ha sido liberado y además no han
recuperado una figura que tuvieron
durante la época de obama era una
persona encargada especialmente de
llevar a cabo el proceso de cierre de la
base de detención tenemos que es una
cuestión complicada todavía quedan 39
personas allí dentro y requiere de
alguien que se encargue de liderar todo
este proceso porque requiere que esta
gente pueda salir de allí por fin
algunos de ellos recordemos que llevan
más de una década que el gobierno de
eeuu ha dicho que pueden marcharse pero
que todavía no han encontrado dónde
pueden ir o no está arreglado toda la
situación y por tanto si ya tienen gente
que han dicho que se pueden marchar de
allí y no han conocido a sacarlos
claramente necesita de un liderazgo
importante que ahora mismo el gobierno
de bailan no está poniendo y esto es lo
que una de las cosas que les reclamamos
y terminamos en áfrica porque naciones
unidas- no ha podido confirmar el
presunto bombardeo que hubo en la región
norteña de tigre en etiopía y no lo ha
podido por la falta de comunicación en
la zona los reportes preliminares del
organismo estiman que ayer hubo un
ataque aéreo que mató a por lo menos 17
personas y que el viernes hubo otro
bombardeo que mató a por lo menos 50
civiles ante este panorama stephen
dujarric el vocero de la onu advirtió
que el organismo redujo sus movimientos
en el noroeste de tigre
y así llegamos al final de las noticias
pero ustedes esperen más en france24
[Música]